sino defendido y su política de
tolerancia cero contra el coronavirus lo
ha hecho desde un editorial del diario
del pueblo en el que se asegura que es
esencial para salvar vidas y proteger la
economía esa defensa llega cuando por
primera vez algunos chinos se preguntan
si esos encierros tan drásticos están
justificados shanghai en cadena récords
diarios hoy ha notificado 20 mil nuevos
casos pero casi el cien por cien de
ellos son asintomáticos y no se ha
informado aún de ningún fallecimiento
eso explica que muchos shanghaineses
estén perdiendo la paciencia después de
varias semanas y sin que se sepa aún
cuándo terminará el encierro hay un
hastío generalizado y protestas por el
suministro de comida muchos han genes es
se despiertan al alba para ser los
primeros en encargar comida en las
saturadas y más aplicaciones del móvil
casi nunca funciona otra opción es crear
grupos de vecinos para conseguir pedidos
más grandes tampoco funciona en
demasiadas ocasiones porque el problema
en shanghai no es que falte comida sino
que faltan repartido es son apenas
11.000 para atender las necesidades de
más de 26 millones de personas
encerradas en casa